the California governor Gavin Newsom
challenges Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
to debate this is a CBS story on Friday
Newsom tweeted if you want to put it up
and zoom in a little bit Tyler so we can
see this
Hey Ron DeSantis clearly you're
struggling distracted and busy playing
politics with people's lives since you
haven't only overriding need attention
let's take this up and debate I'll bring
my hair gel and you bring your hairspray
name the time before election day and he
tags CNN right so he puts this tweet and
then on Thursday uh Newsome called for
an investigation into Republican
Governor sending busloads of migrants of
Democratic states to protest the Biden
Administration immigration policies
intertweed Newsom specifically call that
DeSantis and Texas governor Abbott over
their cruel policy of busting migrants
out of their states to cities with
Democratic Mayors as part of a political
strategy do you have the sentences
response did you find that one or no so
when you saw this what was your first
reaction when you saw Newsome say this
Adam
oh I think this is A Tale of Two Cities
basically best of times worse at times I
mean this has been kind of coming this
way for a while where basically you have
I mean you have the free state of
Florida and the lockdown State of
California and you have the two two
figure heads whether you like them or
not these are basically you know the
uh Gen X version of the current
presidency right now the right Biden and
and Trump in their 70s the bind's about
to be 80. here are two guys in there
what DeSantis is what 44 is that the
oldest how old is Newsom in his late 40s
yeah I think this is on the upswing and
I think basically we've seen a lot of uh
recruiting I think didn't uh DeSantis
put up a massive uh
outdoor billboard basically calling out
to Santa's we have two Governors calling
each other out right and uh
it remains to be seen I'd love to see
this debate I'd love to see this debate
I think the whole world would want to
see this debate this is a presidential
debate if you ask yeah but go ahead
Newsome is an opportunist he and that
means it's like Pharaoh O'Rourke I just
like like when Beto when the gun
violence down in Texas he took Advanced
that because he's running for governor
he has uh presidential dreams and he's
he's an opportunist and I mean that in
the most negative connotation ever he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about any of this
stuff he just wants to become president
so keep talking I'm choking
this is the beauty of having a twin
brother looks just like you and of exact
same opinions you could be choking your
brother just picks up the ball and goes
with it and he's spending a lot of money
that was donated to him right for these
these Billboards because he doesn't have
to worry about spending money in
California because that's just you know
majority that you know even though that
whole state is red for the most part is
San Francisco LA make that whole state
blue he doesn't have to worry about you
know losing seats to demo I mean to
Republicans because that state is just
just blue from those two major cities
why do you think the scientist keeps
getting elected even during the recall I
mean he was the mayor of San Francisco
San Francisco that place has turned into
an absolute [ __ ] right okay then he
becomes a governor of California we've
seen what's going on I think you know
they they have the first year ever Pat
correct me if I'm wrong they had a net
loss in Immigration people that move in
the [ __ ] out of California yeah he has
to recall he beats Larry houndour easily
I don't understand how do they keep vote
for this how do these election results
come in it's just weird
it's like how do Democrats have that
much power in one state well I mean it's
the most liberal state in the country
I'm not shocked I'm not convinced that
it is though because when we do comedy
shows out there people turn out there as
if I'm in Florida really yes how recent
um I mean we have like where's up in um
I forget that City Bakersfield and the
other well the Bakersfield Bakers these
are these are conservative cities
California like whenever we go anywhere
in California it sells out I mean fast
yeah
yeah well what's the population I think
there's 40 million people in California
I mean there's going to be if one third
of California is Republican so you still
got 15 million people there here's my
thoughts on the Newsome uh yeah go for
it DeSantis uh uh debate okay so for me
I could care less about being a CNN
format Newsome here's my suggestion to
you choose a podcast format go for three
hours okay and do it this way you come
to us okay there you go we will
guarantee three hours we'll guarantee
minimum a million dollars to both just
to participate to your campaign we'll do
a super chat people will be able to call
in all that other stuff but it shouldn't
be two minutes I'll stop now okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay no no no no no
no no no I want to see if the Santa I
want to see if Newsom can talk for 10
minutes with an answer and I want to see
if the Santa's gonna give a long answer
so right what do you think about the
issues that we're facing and and let let
it be a different kind of a format
you'll get the money's worth I wouldn't
go to CNN I wouldn't go to Fox I would
go to a podcast pick and choose a
three-hour podcast a lot of people do it
just the other last week we broke the
record for the longest podcast to go you
know whatever it was for the week we got
five five and a half million views on
yeah we crossed five million five hour
podcast got
200 million minutes watched on this one
podcast that we got last week that went
out on Tuesday or Monday I don't know
what it was it was there correct right
after I'd love to if it's not us choose
somebody else okay pick somebody else
and but have the sit down because if you
guys are gonna do the traditional way I
have zero interest in watching it yeah I
would love to see a bigger move in
campaigns going like I'd love to see
those guys sitting down with a Rogan
okay sitting down over here sitting down
in a place where it's three hours a good
moderator ask challenge each other and
let's see what it's gonna look like yeah
any other format is just disingenuous
it's not enough time you're not giving
it's totally fake yeah that's right how
can you have somebody you having a open
conversation with somebody but they're
on your side and they're just throwing
you softball questions though yeah you
know it's just it's just because I don't
trust anything you know for the most
part on TV because you have to double
check everything you heard yeah and by
the way the cool thing about this kind
of a format is do if you if you tell a
lie the audience in the chat box chat
but they're gonna go off the live chat
right right so versus when they're doing
it there there's not you know everybody
has to but everyone's like oh my god did
you know what they said it's a very
different format that a lot of these
guys fear they're not comfortable doing
that they would much rather be in a
controlled environment where they get to
control the end the question they come
on a podcast it's like a brawl yeah but
that's what America does so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here